[Musique]
il ya un nouveau racontions l'histoire
de fabien voulait ce jeune français
partis en voyage en 2017 à istanbul et
qui n'est jamais revenu est détenu en
prison depuis quatre ans maintenant dans
une prison du nord-est de la turquie et
des condamnés à saison et du mois de
prison pour avoir commandé du gbl
stupéfiants alors interdit depuis peu en
turquie dès la livraison il est
interpellé puis jugés l'année suivante
pour trafic et consommation de drogue
mais si l'histoire de fabien vous a
autant bouleversé c'est parce que ses
conditions de détention sont inhumaines
personne ne peut imaginer des horreurs
auxquelles j'ai assisté comme son
avocate maître caroline vient montenot
la dcri il est enfermé 24 heures sur 24
cette pétition a été lancée pour tenter
de transférer le jeune homme et le
ramener auprès des siens en france hier
soir cyril a promis d'essayer de faire
bouger les choses
essayez peut-être d'avoir l'ambassadeur
de turquie en france dans l'émission
dans les prochains jours que ce soir
c'est l'ambassadeur de turquie en france
alliés aux mânes heures qui viennent
s'exprimer sur le sujet
monsieur l'ambassadeur merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation à lyon danner
donc ambassadeur de turquie en france
vous avez suivi le dossier de fabien
sous les pieds de plus en plus médiatisé
en france on le voyait depuis ce
week-end encore plus hier soir sur ce
plateau ses proches nous parler de
conditions de détention incroyable
terribles de sa détresse de ces lettres
de ses envies de suicide et ir soir je
suis persuadé que tous les gens qui nous
regardent
je suis sûr qu'ils ont repensé avant de
se coucher à fabien azoulay mois ses
fruits surtout si si ouais autour de la
table aussi est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles des gens alors l'essentiel
c'est que aujourd'hui il est dans la
nouvelle prison vers laquelle il a été
déplacé où il est en totale sécurité ou
les conditions de détention sont plus
avantageuses puisqu'il rencontre moins
deux personnes et donc les autorités
pénitentiaires en turquie ont pris
toutes les mesures nécessaires après le
regrettable problèmes qu'il a vécu en
effet un des co détenus a exercé
différentes formes de violence contre
lui ce qui est inacceptable et ce dont
on peut se féliciter c'est que les
responsables des prisons ont pris les
mesures pour le mettre en sécurité
donc ça c'est une première chose et tout
généralement sur les conditions
d'incarcération en turquie aujourd'hui
donc nous avons parfois cette fausse
image de ce qui a été dit sur les
prisons turques dans les années 70
aujourd'hui heureusement pour les
détenus en turquie la situation dans les
prisons en turquie sont du niveau égal
ou supérieur à la moyenne européenne
ceci étant dit chaque détenu qui est
loin de son pays chaque détenu étrangers
a le droit de demander ce qu'on appelle
en un transfèrement n'est sûr nous avons
régulièrement ce type de demandes pour
des détenus turque en france qui demande
à retourner en turquie ring pour être
plus proche de leur famille d'accord la
même manière nous avons actuellement
plusieurs 2
entre deux détenus français en cours
pour pouvoir retourner en france
mais la saison de prison pour le son
délit qui est minime
voilà c'est incompréhensible alors la
longueur de la peine pour mieux la
comprendre il faut imaginer la carte
d'europe et la carte où se trouve la
turquie la turquie étant
géographiquement sur les voies de trafic
de stupéfiants malheureusement pour
entre guillemets protéger l'europe
occidentale nous sommes obligés d'avoir
des lois très dur pour dissuader les
trafiquants de drogue et malheureusement
ces lois dur pour dissuader les
trafiquants de drogue peuvent affecter
des personnes individuelles qui
objectivement ne sont pas des
trafiquants mais qui ont fait l'erreur
par erreur de choix de commander une
somme importante de litres dont on peut
pas parler de consommation personnelle
mais on peut légitimement penser que ce
n'est pas le trafiquant type donc du
coup les tribunaux turcs juge en
fonction des lois qui sont durs mais
j'ai expliqué pourquoi ils sont lieu
d'ailleurs le débat dans ce cas
particulier c'est ne pas ce n'est pas de
savoir la longueur de la peine puisque
donc le détenu en question reconnaît le
crime qu'on lui reproche sa demande
n'est pas une réduction de peine
sa demande est un transfèrement parce
qu'il sait il sait très bien que si
voilà il y ait sa peine il y aura en
france à mon avis il en france alors sur
ça aussi il ne faut pas avancer des
hypothèses dès le départ parce que il y
à certaines conditions qui sont donc
déterminés par le traité international
relatifs au transfèrement
donc il ne faut pas émettre des
hypothèses al avance par rapport au
nombre d'années qu'il devra passer en
prison en france
d'accord le but n'étant pas de réduire
là
durée en prison mais son transfèrement
en france comme il l'a souhaité pour
qu'ils puissent être proche de sa
famille ça c'est l'essentiel c'est vrai
que il ya une question qui revient et
que mon c'est nenê proche de fabien
monte envoyé de mot ils demandent de
vous demander pourquoi il ya une peine
si longue de 20 ans réduite est réduite
à 16 ans et huit mois pour bonne
conduite
alors on a parlé de la durée de la peine
tout à l'heure la situation géographique
de la turquie fait que le trafic de
produits stupéfiants est pénalisée de
manière très dieu c'est une obligation
parce que nous sommes sur les voies de
trafic international
oui donc ce détenu ayant peut-être à la
suite d'une erreur on ne sait pas
apparemment commander une grande
quantité de ce produit n'a pas pu donc
convaincre les tribunaux que cette
énorme quantité et sa consommation la
personnel c'est de là que donc son
jugement
avec une peine qui correspond à un
trafiquant de produits stupéfiants a dû
être décidée par le tribunal
mais je ne je ne connais pas les détails
du jugement
le sujet dont nous avons parlé c'est sa
demande de transfèrement
justement voir parler dans un instant
mais est-ce qu'il est victime on a pris
on l'a vu hier il est victime de
violence en prison à cause de ça de sa
religion de son orientation sexuelle
alors je n'ai pas cette information
détaillée l'information que dont je
dispose c'est que un codétenu lui a
malheureusement c'est regrettable
infligé une violence je n'ai pas c'est
ce que nous a dit son avocate hier une
casserole show de verser de l'eau chaude
sur sur les plans qui dans mais ça vous
de l'avocate a plus de détails là le
genre je n'ai pas tous les détails mais
et donc je ne sais pas non plus
exactement quelles étaient les
motivations du codétenu
l'essentiel c'est que transféré dans une
autre prison
le co détenu a dû rendre des comptes et
a reçu une peine pour cette violence et
donc monsieur azoulay a été transféré
dans une autre prison où il est beaucoup
plus isolé donc il ne il n'y a aucun
risque de rencontrer une nouvelle fois
ce type de violence alors oui il ya
quelque chose que je comprends pas
depuis donc maintenant quatre ans oui
j'avais donc un français qui est là bas
on n'a aucune nouvelle de lui au départ
vous êtes assez proche quoi du ministre
des affaires en turquie des ambassadeurs
pour la troisième fois en france donc
c'est une affaire comme une affaire
d'état puisque on parle de brûler mais
on parle de brûler on parle aussi de
violer on parle aussi de battue donc
c'est quelque chose de grave
aujourd'hui on connait tous les
relations tendues entre la france et
l'afrique est entre les présidents donc
à un moment donné je pense que vous en
savez un peu plus que ce que vous êtes
en train de nous dire comment on peut
régler ce problème c'est un problème
extrêmement grave alors est ce que c'est
un geste humanitaire aujourd'hui j'en
sais rien mais on peut pas rester comme
ça on va pas continuer à se parler comme
ça déjà les journées passent l'homme
l'homme et a de loisirs donc c'est un
moment donné c'est l'ambassadeur en
france c'est dangereux pour pour fabien
voulait on a peur que voilà qu'est ce
que vous répondez à ça je veux dire même
pas la donne nous en dire plus que ça
j'ai l'impression d'être un peu longue
de ceux d'en bas salaires mais pour être
très concret il faut laisser cette
procédure purement judiciaire et
administrative suivre son coup et
s'assurer qu'il n'y a aucun retard que
toutes les étapes nécessaires en
fonction des traités internationaux sont
franchies sans avoir de retard
c'est le 4 ont harcelé ses mots a
terminé parce que essayé et de lier
cette demande tout à fait légitime d'un
détenu avec les relations politiques et
insinuer que ceux détenus pourraient
être renvoyés ou relâché par décision
politique n'est pas acceptable ni pour
la justice française
mais pour la justice turque ce qui est
essentiel c'est que cette demande de
transfèrement a été fait je pense à
elles et attaquons maintenant un peu
moins de deux ans je crois et et pour
votre information
c'est pas votre information les
formalités de transfèrement peuvent être
conclues en moyenne autour de 3 ans et
nous avons parlé
malheureusement des détenus turque en
france qui demandent leur transfèrement
en turquie mais qui pour certains depuis
quatre ans n'ont pas eu satisfaction
donc il faut voir cette question de
manière plus globale
en tout cas ce qui est important c'est
que la situation particulière
la vulnérabilité de ce détenu en
question est connu un et l'autre raison
là il est long en sécurité pour vous il
est en totale sécurité et il a lui il
est sept détenus avec lui en il soit 8
dans la cellule
on m'a dit dans sa cellule actuellement
à ma connaissance ils ne sont pas aussi
nombreux c'est ce que c'est les
milliards
un avocat si l'avocate a accordé ces les
informations plus récentes
je ne contredirai pas l'avocate met donc
l'avocate pourra vous confirmer que
depuis que les mesures nécessaires ont
été prises il ne risque pas eu un acte
violent dans la prison il se trouve ça
c'est l'essentiel
et ensuite sa détresse psychologique on
peut tout à fait très bien la comprendre
le niveau auquel cette question était
médiatisée permettra à tous les acteurs
impliqués dans cette danse et formalités
juridiques et administratives de
travailler rapidement pour que l'on
puisse finaliser cette demande le plus
tôt possible et gilles verdez monsieur
l'ambassadeur j'entends parfaitement
qu'il fallait respecter les procédures
mais on a quand même l'impression judici
que monsieur azoulay pour nous est un
prisonnier presque politique exactement
donc la décision chez vous avec la toute
puissance de votre président monsieur
erdogan
elle peut venir de lui pourquoi est ce
que la turquie ne fait pas un geste
humanitaire ce soir libérer un
prisonnier qui aujourd'hui est en train
de mourir monsieur l'ambassadeur met en
prison en france le terme de prisonniers
politiques n'est pas adapté par
définition puisque cette personne a
commis un délit ou il reconnaît l'avoir
commis et sur ce point là ya pas de king
ensuite au lieu d'un transfèrement si la
demande avait été faite pour une grâce
présidentielle
ce que n'ont pas choisi les avocats de
faire c'est un choix des avocats c'est
les avocats qui en connaissance de cause
qui sachant que les procédures de
transfèrement prennent en moyenne entre
la france et bien sûr qu'il ya autour de
trois ans c'est les avocats qui ont fait
cette demande
ensuite vous savez que aussi bien en
france qu en turquie dans tous les pays
européens
les demandes de grâce présidentielle
sont quelque chose de très exceptionnel
et la génération est exceptionnel
généralement les trafiquants de drogue
en france ne bénéficient que très
rarement de grâce présidentielle donc
c'est pour ça il faut poser la question
à leur avocate
c'est leur avocat qu'ils ont décidé et
de faire une demande de transfert à ce
qu'ils savaient très bien que les grâces
présidentielles
notre responsabilité en tant
qu'administration en tant qu'ambassade
en tant que ministère de la justice
respectifs des deux pays
c'est de nous assurer que cette
procédure soit conclue rapidement et
qu'aucun retard soir mais la turquie
sortirait grandie d'un geste humanitaire
surpris bernard montiel
excellence vous savez que vous évoquez
plusieurs fois des prisonniers turcs qui
sont emprisonnés chez nous est-ce qu'il
serait envisageable parce que nous on
veut le sauver ce garçon mais il rate le
blabla la diplomatie a sûrement sauvé ce
garçon donc le reste c'est de la
littérature ou de la diplomatie vous
êtes expert et bravo vous faites très
bien visiblement je vous écoute en
revanche vous me parlez plusieurs fois
de thé prisionniers turcs chez nous
est-ce qu'il serait envisageable
un échange de prisonniers alors bien sûr
mais ça ne serait pas appeler un échange
puisque ce ne sont pas des prisonniers
et de guerre qu on échangerait mais
c'est des détenus qui dans chaque pays
respectifs ont commis des délits
ensuite ce qui serait bien sûr utiles
parce que dans ces cas de transfèrement
il ya toujours aussi l'importance de la
réciprocité
donc si un pays tiers rang mais citoyen
au bout de cinq ans seulement
je serai moins motivés pour rendre leurs
citoyens pour leur tournée leurs
citoyens la caisse comme aux besoins
mais alors je veux ajouter une chose
paraît la bonne pratique de la turquie
c'est que nous avons par habitude
d'essayer d'appliquer cette réciprocité
par la positive
donc si et en france un détenu turc
n'a pas pu retourner depuis quatre ans
nous n'allons pas dire à la france nous
allons retenir votre détenu pendant
quatre ans au contraire nous allons
essayer de résoudre cette question le
plus rapidement possible j'espère au
bout de trois ans et ensuite nous
pourrons dire aux autorités françaises
que nous avons fait l'effort de résoudre
au bout de trois ans et qu'il ne faut
plus faire attendre nos demandes plus de
trois ans mais donc 5 sera l'ambassadeur
quelque chose à utiliser pour une
solution immédiate est-ce que vous en
avez parlé avec le président de la
république
non cette donne en dos et non pas aux
pas à ce stade pas à ce stade
est ce que vous comptez bien en parler
alors ce n'est pas parmi vous parlez du
président de la république française ce
n'est pas un sujet que moi j' aborderai
en priorité si lui ressent le besoin de
ces demain le président de la république
on va on passe à la dernière partie se
prête
merci si demain le président de la
république vous appelle et vous dit
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse quelque
chose pour fabien azoulay qu'est ce que
vous feriez je transmettrai
immédiatement cette demande d'un
président de la république français au
président turc
mais est-ce que vous pensez que mais je
le répète est ce que vous pensez que ça
peut 7
ça peut avoir une issue sur le
transfèrement plus rapide très
franchement non non puisque même si le
président français devrait franchement
non puisque eux ce type d'intervention
politique pourrait accélérer les choses
si donc l'administration perdez du temps
alors que ici puisque vous accorder de
l'importance à cette question accélérer
dans les prochains jours les
administrations françaises turques
auront maintenant mais deux ans et
beaucoup à l'avènement rasant donc là ça
donc là vous pensez qu'au bout de trois
ans il va être transféré comme c'est ce
que j'ai dit non mais donc il restera
encore un an dans cette prison il est
impossible pour moi de m'engager
d'émettre une hypothèse par rapport au
temps restant donc mais est ce que ça
peut s'accélérer ce que dans les
prochains jours vous avez parlé de
de deux le matin exactement voilà vous
avez parlé aussi de mon à médiatiser
cette affaire
est ce que ça peut faire que ça
s'accélère ou pas du tout alors tous vos
efforts l'intérêt que vous avez porté à
cette question va permettre aux
administrations de traiter cela le plus
rapidement possible ensuite si on essaie
de pousser la chose jusqu'à demander une
intervention politique
à mon sens très sincèrement ça ne peut
être que contre productif
vous avez votre homologue anthuriums je
ne lui ai pas parlé à ce sujet là mais
par contre une bonne nouvelle donc
concernant ce sujet particulier le
ministre le vice ministre de la justice
turque va assez bientôt recevoir
l'ambassadeur de france en quarts 1 et
cette question pourrait être discuté
donc ils vont parler soyez en sûr les
administrations sont informés de
l'importance accordée à cette question
là et je suis convaincu qu'il n'y aura
aucun retard qui seraient évitables